[Música]
hace un tiempo estaba en un bar
en otra mesa había una mujer con su hijo
de unos cinco años
s estaba completamente capturada por su
celular
y mientras el nene la miraba
tal vez otro chico hubiera hecho el lío
para tratar de llamar su atención pero
éste no
espero un buen rato finalmente se paró
de su silla fue detrás de su mamá y
empezó a acariciar le el pelo
intento convocarla con caricias durante
varios minutos
y ella en ningún momento se dio cuenta
de lo que estaba pasando
me invadió la pregunta
cuántas veces habría estado yo en la
misma situación sin siquiera darme
cuenta
qué nos está pasando
porque vivimos obsesionados por nuestras
pantallas
hoy desbloqueamos el celular 150 veces
al día
esto es una vez cada seis minutos
durante el tiempo que pasamos despiertos
decidí investigar sobre el tema y llegué
a una conclusión que me impactó
lo que nos está pasando con la
tecnología
no es casualidad
la universidad stanford está ubicada en
el corazón de silicon valley la cuna de
las mayores compañías tecnológicas del
mundo
ahí tiene su sede el laboratorio de
tecnología persuasiva
donde investigadores brillantes trabajan
de acuerdo a sus propias palabras para
ver cómo usar las páginas web y las
aplicaciones móviles que utilizamos para
manipular lo que pensamos
y lo que hacemos
intentar persuadir a los demás es tan
viejo como el mundo
pero los dispositivos digitales y el
enorme volumen de información personal
acumulado acerca de nosotros a partir de
nuestra actividad online están creando
una vía nueva de manipular nuestros
pensamientos y acciones aprovechando las
vulnerabilidades de la mente detectadas
por la economía del comportamiento la
psicología y la neurociencia
los ejemplos abundan
en la escala social los intentos por
manipular elecciones la proliferación de
noticias falsas el agrandamiento de
todas las grietas
en la órbita personal
padres que no vemos a nuestros hijos y
al revés
reuniones donde cada uno está más
preocupado por lo que pasa en su
pantalla que por lo que pasa a su
alrededor
una dificultad cada vez más grande para
concentrarnos
este fenómeno empezó con la expectativa
inicial de que todo en internet tenía
que ser gratuito
un grupo de compañías tuvo que encontrar
la manera de ganar dinero sin cobrarle a
los usuarios
lo primero que hicieron fue poner
publicidad y empezar a cobrar a los
anunciantes
después vino empezar a recopilar este
montón de datos personales para ultra
segmentar el mensaje que nos dan a cada
una finalmente para aumentar sus
ganancias cada compañía necesito que
pasáramos más y más tiempo en su
plataforma
así nació el hackeo de nuestra atención
cuando el producto que las empresas
venden es tu atención todos compiten
contra todos
facebook compite contra otra red social
como twitter pero también compite con
productos muy diferentes como youtube
netflix o four night
cada segundo que no estás ahí
hipnotizado
es tiempo que ellos no pueden vender a
sus anunciantes
por eso utilizan notificaciones visuales
y sonoras y todo tipo de trucos para
distraerte de cualquier cosa que estés
haciendo inclusive cuando estás usando
las demás plataformas
el primer presidente de facebook se
convirtió hace un tiempo en un
arrepentido
en una presentación con todo que él y
mark zuckerberg eran absolutamente
conscientes al desarrollar la plataforma
de estar explotando vulnerabilidades de
nuestra mente para maximizar el efecto
adictivo
pero no fue el único en reconocer el uso
de estos mecanismos abusivos
recientemente el fundador de netflix
declaró que su mayor enemigo
es el sueño
su meta es que durmamos menos para que
pasemos más tiempo mirando series
y vender los productos que no nos hacen
bien tampoco es nuevo pero al menos los
ejecutivos de compañías como las
tabacaleras actuaban a la defensiva
el fundador de netflix no tiene reparos
en decirnos de frente que su compañía
está dispuesta a inducir los hábitos
totalmente contrarios a nuestra salud
con tal de ganar más plata
para alcanzar estos fines
necesitan de nuestra ingenuidad
cuando vamos a comprar un producto
digamos un par de zapatos tenemos cierta
desconfianza nos preguntamos cosas como
serán cómodos tendrán buena calidad
estaré pagando un precio razonable
pero con el producto es gratis
bajamos la guardia
si el producto es gratis tendríamos que
desconfiar mucho más todavía
porque querría una gran empresa
multinacional incurrir en los enormes
costos de desarrollar una red social una
plataforma de videos un sistema de
correo electrónico para que lo usemos
gratis
nada es gratis en el mundo de las
empresas
si no estamos pagando con dinero
de qué otra manera estaremos pagando
una área de manipulación especialmente
sensible es la autoestima
el creciente uso de fotos y vídeos como
lenguaje principal en las redes le da
una importancia absurda desproporcionada
al aspecto estético y el aspecto físico
por sobre todas las demás dimensiones de
nuestra persona frente a los ojos de los
demás y por lo tanto de nosotros mismos
y las redes aprovechan las redes
aprovechan la fascinación que nos causa
espiar las vidas ajenas e impactar a los
demás con nuestra propia imagen para
mantenernos indefinidamente cautivados
más aún
dado que cada uno de nosotros comparte
contenido muy poco espontáneo de los
momentos más destacados de nuestro día y
convenientemente editado para que
parezcan mucho mejor de lo que fue
cuando después vamos en el colectivo
apretados aburridos mirando una red
social resulta inevitable que tengamos
la errónea sensación de que somos los
únicos que tenemos una vida común más
llena de obligaciones y percances que de
risas y puestas de sol
es inevitable que la comparación contra
estos falsos ideales nos deje
desilusionados respecto de nuestra
propia vida
la decisión de a quien seguimos y que
mostramos es clave para romper los
efectos de este espejo distorsionado
si bien siempre fue cierto que había
personas más populares y otros más
retraídos de alguna manera esto está
implícito
hoy se mide
y está a la vista de todos
los me gusta y la cantidad de seguidores
son la moneda en la que hoy se comercia
la aceptación social
y cada acto queda sujeto a la
cuantificación pública
de la cantidad de me gusta que recibe
como resultado
empezamos a vivir la vida para mostrarla
no para disfrutarla
ese es el pantano narcisista en el que
las redes nos metieron y del que
curiosamente
no queremos salir
el deseo de encontrar a alguien a quien
amar y ser amados nos deje en una
posición especialmente vulnerable
el mes pasado la secretaria de defensa
del consumidor de eeuu demandó a la
mayor empresa mundial de citas
los acusa de aprovecharse de la
desesperación de quienes no están
pudiendo encontrar pareja para permitir
que sean contactados de perfiles falsos
invitarlos a pagar para entrar en
contacto con estas personas inexistentes
que después jamás devolverán sus
mensajes
realmente vale todo para retenerlos como
usuarios y quedarse con nuestro dinero
otro grupo especialmente atractivo y que
resulta un blanco fácil son nuestros
chicos
es la adolescencia el momento donde la
manipulación de la autoestima encuentra
el terreno más fértil pero el problema
empieza mucho antes que eso
los bebés también han sido descubiertos
como un nuevo tarde el consumidor
youtube está lleno de vídeos
específicamente diseñados para cautivar
los
a pesar de que la recomendación de la
organización mundial de la salud es que
los menores de 2 años no pasen ni un
segundo frente a pantallas la realidad
es bien diferente
el promedio de tiempo hoy para chicos de
2 años es de 2 horas y media al día
y un tercio de los bebés utiliza
pantallas desde antes de caminar
en esta etapa crucial del desarrollo del
sistema nervioso y de la psiquis el
chupete electrónico se está convirtiendo
en un tentador escape para los padres y
está reemplazando al contacto físico el
uso de la palabra
y los juegos de crianza
muchos padres incluso se enorgullecen de
la habilidad de sus bebés para manejar
los dispositivos
ven lo que sus hijos aprenden con estos
vídeos los animales los colores
pero no ven los aprendizajes y
experiencias que se pierden varios
estudios científicos están empezando ya
a mostrar las consecuencias negativas de
este cambio en áreas como la adquisición
del lenguaje el tiempo de atención y el
desarrollo socioemocional
el riesgo más grande para nuestros
chicos no es el uso temprano de
pantallas
sino el corrimiento excesivo de los
adultos
frente a esto hay algunas personas que
dicen después de todo es lo mismo de
siempre en los 40 el villano era la
radio en los 60 era la televisión en los
80 los videojuegos y ahora es esto para
sócrates el villano de la escritura
siempre hay algo que los mayores
demonizan simplemente porque es nuevo
pero esta vez es distinto
porque si vienen por inercia seguimos
llamando teléfono celular a la
supercomputadora ultra liviana que cada
uno lleva consigo
este aparato
es
todo
es un celular pero es también una cámara
de fotos un televisor un gps una consola
de juegos una filmadora navegador a
internet una linterna un reloj
despertador una calculadora un equipo de
música y muchas cosas más
no solo es todo
está con nosotros en todo lugar y en
todo momento ofreciendo la promesa de un
flujo ilimitado de contenido capaz de
llenar el vacío de cada instante de
nuestra vida
y sin embargo en esta era de hiper
comunicación los estudios muestran que
la cantidad de gente que se siente sola
jamás fue tan alta como ahora
no hay peor soledad que la soledad
rodeado de gente y todo esto se va a
poner peor
hasta ahora sólo un puñado de compañías
aplicaba estos mecanismos pero nuevos
emprendimientos están desarrollando
software para llevar estos métodos
manipulativos a todos los productos
digitales
el uso de la manipulación y el hackeo de
nuestra atención recién están comenzando
qué hacemos entonces
abandonamos los celulares y damos de
baja a las redes sociales no hace falta
llegar a tanto las ventajas de la vida
conectada son demasiado grandes como
para renunciar a ellas
pero estamos en una lucha desigual entre
compañías muy sofisticadas y usuarios
que a todos los con ingenuidad
firmamos un contrato escrito por la otra
parte sin siquiera poder leer ni saber
qué diablos estamos firmando
para nivelar la cancha necesitamos
entender cómo funcionan estos mecanismos
para poder defendernos de la
manipulación
si nos preguntamos como cada una de
estas compañías gana dinero resulta más
fácil tratar de imaginar qué tipo de
conductas pueden querer estar induciendo
en nosotros y qué tipo de información
pueden estar procurando para hacerlo
por ejemplo la próxima vez que use es
una aplicación de citas tened presente
que el negocio de estas compañías es que
busques
no que encuentres
los dispositivos y las redes nos
mantienen ensimismados
distraídos
impacientes
y enfocados en el consumo pasivo
pero no tiene por qué ser así
es momento de abandonar la ingenuidad y
lanzar la contraofensiva
podemos recuperar el control de nuestra
vida para aprovechar los beneficios de
la tecnología sin quedar atrapados en
ella
y aprovechar la supercomputadora que
llevamos con nosotros para crear
no solo para consumir
usarla para vivir experiencias
compartidas en vez de quedar cada uno
encerrado en su propia pantalla
en definitiva el desafío es poner las
plataformas y los dispositivos al
servicio de la vida que queremos vivir
no de la vida que otros
necesitan que vivamos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
[Aplausos]